sapphire gagner de l'argent c'est de
parler la presse people et c'est qu'en
balançant des choses igas de l'argent
donc les enfants entendre ça et
détestent leur mère
nabil a malheureusement dû prendre un
vol commercial pour rentrer de vacances
dubaï est là si les alors à votre avis
pour conclure je l'aï dit moi je pense
que c'est un problème de sur bagages
absolument qu'est ce qui s'est passé est
ce que des voyages énormément avec de
bons gars tout son maquillage tous ces
substances il tout ce que tu veux à l'as
pas compris arrivée à l'aéroport dans ce
vol commercial qu'on lui ai dit vous
allez droit à 25 kg de bagages c'était
juste son maquillage finalement de
google a dit comment je fais machin
alors jeté des fils lui pris 6 at il
quelqu'un sait mais elle a aussi ses
enfants donc on en joue dit la vérité
elle avait 16 malle vuitton est ce que
j'ai déjà fait
quand on a un bébé rivaux direction des
effets d'enfants dans des larves et
quand elle avait 16 mal vu ton est
effectivement normalement cela s'est
même pas que les les valises doit pas
dépasser 32 kg quand on a ce qu'on
appelle du org il faut préciser prendre
un avion cargo et préciser ce qu'elle
n'a pas dû faire elle a dû donc tout
laisse à los angeles acheté deux trois
sacs pour mettre le nécessaire et elle a
poussé un coup de gueule vol commercial
parce que j'avais quinze valises
forcément j'avais acheté j'ai toutes mes
valises qu'ils aient pour prendre de
kilos peuvent oublier la rolls des 32 kg
en fait si on peut avoir plein de
valises mais faut pas qu'elle déballe
ses 32 kg du coup on a dû tout rouvrir
acheter une valise à l'aéroport
remplir faire des calculs
l'un qu'est ce qui se passe dans l'avion
je dois faire un biberon donc un monfils
j'ai pas le petit truc le doseur je
commence à paniquer je ne savais pas
quelle dose m ensuite j'ai passé un
contrôle ils voulaient pas passer mon
nous car ils m'ont dit oui l'eau vous
pouvez pas d'apprendre que j'étais en
racheter mais lmp1 hybride aux fins d
des aurores il m'arrivait des horreurs
les gars et c'est cette phrase qui a
choqué tout le monde est peut-être
était-elle en colère écoutez moi bien
plus jamais je ne prendrai de vols
d'avions normaux de vols commerciaux
donc que
écran on en est où là elle se déplacer
pour des raisons professionnelles elle
devait rentrer ça aurait des enfants
c'est son tram dit m
elle vit avec certains moyens et c'est
proportionnel à ce qu'elle est ce
qu'elle gagne c'est son mode de vie elle
avait tous ces enfants et ces [ __ ]
mais dire oh non mais dire à des gens au
5 mai l'action voilà quand tu sais qu'il
est franchement je chope est démago co2
c'est qu'un français sur deux qui
partent pas en vacances ya 22 ans et
drôle à 3,5 c'est m non c'est pas des
réseaux n'étaient pas démago j'aurai un
jet je le prends ça peut lire je prends
je vous dis franchement mais bon je sois
pas une vidéo tient il à deux heures de
retard mon geste ps tu vas nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le titre qu'à la sortie parce que ne
restait plus rien soit 5 millions
d'euros elle a quitté les réseaux
sociaux elle était vraiment des prêts
cible elton john c'est son pote et
madonna aussi et c'est madonna qui a
appelé le ltte john et qu il écoute tu
as fait un truc super u de l'ipa va
l'aider tout ce que je vous raconte les
vrais il a appelé ça a donné ça c'est
premier single qu'elle sortait depuis
six ans ses premiers dans 40 pays sa
valeur lors la relance est
annoncée en cali le sortant ils ont tué
un peu sa carrière ils ont tué sa
personnalité ont tué son fils ils ont
tous fait de l'enfermer était dans une
cage dorée avait le droit de voir
personne attend compte que la même dit
que ces trois derniers disent que les
trois d'un indice était pas le cas chez
son père l'a empêché de retirer son
stérilet pour qu'elle tombe enceinte
mais c'est quand même affreux alors elle
à langoat sa mère surtout de ne rien
avoir avec sa soeur ouais mais c'est une
hyper sensible je pense que tout le
monde a profité d'elle à un moment donné
je peux comprendre les concevoir qu'elle
est plus envie de parler à personne
d'autre mais la mère sa femme et sa
propre famille l'a trahie et très on
peut comprendre qu'elle ait pété un
câble et est ce que vous savez pire du
pire du pire ces enfants ne veut plus le
voir si des raisons pour lesquelles il
ne voulait plus voir leur mère c'est
toutes ses photos et ses vidéos riz à
moitié nue complètement un peu dans le
gaz non mais dites yérim tard dans
l'année ce qui fait comme il peut rien
lui ne gagnent pas d'argent sa fille à
rien de gagner de l'argent c'est de
parler la presse people c'est qu'en
balançant des choses du gaz de l'argent
donc les enfants entendent ça et
détestent leur mère oui mais mathieu n'y
a pas que ça se fait hier britney spears
est revenu sur instagram son compte
avait été suspendue à la vertu dans mr
ouai la rue ni on a un poste instagram
où elle met tout un texte où elle
explique beaucoup de choses elle parle
principalement de son ex kevin federline
où finalement elles l'accusent d'avoir
finalement monter ses enfants contre
elle donc en fait elle entre sa famille
son ex en gros elle n'a que ses enfants
aient mariage c'est l'union c'est
l'union qui a fait vraiment le plus de
bruit cet été j lo bann avec le couple
d'une cinquantaine d'années a mis les
petits plats dans les grands tudieu de
la cérémonie aux banques et pas son
barbecue géant en passant par la
somptueuse robe de mariée de gillot tout
a été minutieusement
et c'est propre une magnifique traîne de
6 mètres de long signée ralph lauren qui
aurait coûté pas moins de 400 mille
dollars à la star la star a opté pour
une paire de boucles d'oreilles à 53
mille dollars il a serti de diamants
d'une valeur de 39 dollars rien que ça
c'est vous vous vous dites 8 millions de
dollars un mariage 380 mille euros pour
une robe est alors des boucles
d'oreilles à 2 millions d'euros mais
voilà les gens chez eux c'est
ben beau non enfin moi je suis pas
choqué c'est son fric elle l'a gagné
alors que du divertissement à tout le
monde ça fait 20 ans et son plus beau
mariage à vous attaquer à 8 millions $
c'est son problème allez pas envoyer les
sept autres millions $ par année pendant
cinq ans du lion surtout il sait dans
quel pays on sait pas encore sionnel
c'est proportionnel et enel elle est à
la tête d'une fortune de 400 millions
d'années que lui doit avoir des soucis
j'imagine souviennent ils vont pas faire
un mariage à 200000 euros alors ça
paraît choquant mais ce qui met qui sont
choqués je m'excuse et moi vous êtes
contre la société capitaliste mais c'est
le principe ça ne cicatrisera
dépenser leur argent comme vous j'ai
encore le droit de la famille millions
de dollars c'est une grave et il aurait
pu
s'appeler j'ai pas dit que je n'aurais
jamais fait j'ai dit oh toi j'ai le don
la bad choqué qu'on puisse dépenser
autant dosé dans un mariage excusez moi
mais à l'époque en jeu et sa femme
avaient dépensé à peu près 7 millions
d'euros je crois pour leur mariage eux
par contre avait invité avait payé tous
l'aider d'avion avait invité dans des
heures dans un hôtel manny sid humain
pour les enfants etc c'était une chose
des sciences occultes ou en gros ce
qu'il faut c'est que tu vas marguerittes
et pensent beaucoup d'argent en évitant
du monde en gros il faut partager plutôt
que se dire j'ai craqué j'ai essayé et
on la rend dirigeants mais tant mieux
elle a fait tourner une boutique qui a
vendu la bague et qu'elle avait en
vitrine et tant mieux ça a fait bosser
du monde sait bien il faudra pas n'ont
pas d'ena jean luc mélenchon qui veut
dire un mot
moi pardon je veux juste faire un rappel
à la décence la juncasse jamais très
simple c'est moi j'ai rien contre
l'organisation fastueuse les voitures
etc tout ce qui va avec par contre la
bague rien que la bague parce que c'est
un exemple parlant à 4 millions de
dollars et or dont il ya des bagues
magnifique a peut-être 200 300 mille
dollars
ouf du coup et qu'elle allait chez tati
or
[Rires]
là je te parle d'une bague à 4 millions
de dollars donc je ne peux pas deviner
chez au fond tu es fou amoureux de sa
femme tuée richissime d'accord tu ne
comptes pas tuer richissime fatah femme
par décence à la
boutique extraordinaire avec une pagaie
millions tu n'as aucun problème
financier sur plusieurs générations tu
l'offre pas ta femme si elle aime à 4
millions mais
je crois les mais
on parlait du mariage jennifer lopez et
gobe lopez ben affleck et je vous avais
dit qu'effectivement il avait signé tous
des contraintes eu beau appeler madame
en as tu signes un contre un et
effectivement si avec ton téléphone tu
prends une photo et qu'elle sort quelque
part et tu perds des millions par contre
a obtenu ça rigole pas donc voilà et
elle avait chanté une chanson et ça a
été volé et mis sur un titre qui a fait
ça
[Musique]
et
où les invités sont en train d'essayer
de trouver alors à l'ami son pote matt
damon sur le coup pour le moment et là
ils sont en train d'aborder ses devoirs
ci avait des caméras et des photographes
il ya des photographes qui reprennent
toutes les photos du mariage pourvoi qui
à ce moment là
risquent gros des millions